>> Yeah.
India is going to become a superpower in the
next 20 years.
Because the reason is the younger generation
now which is getting
educated before -- 40 years, before that literacy
was [INAUDIBLE].
Now that literacy is going to be 75 percent
in the next three or five
years.
And with the literacy and education coming
in and economic condition
going up, and all the ability of the government
policies that are in
place, that is the relaxation in many of the
areas like [INAUDIBLE] and
trade policy and foreign trade policy.
And then youngster people coming in with the
mobile things, like they
have Internet, like they've mobile phones,
like all these things.
So all old impediments are over.
So we can find that India moving to a economic
condition as [INAUDIBLE]
homes are coming down, and all the ability
of the world is coming up
with India, and we are definitely possible
that in India will
definitely become a superpower in the time.